all right it's superlatives time super
bowl 54 edition what do you got first
well i i i mean
like i just want to say like you know s
star i want to go like star power that's
what i'm going to start off with right
away star power and you heard me say it
a little bit on the the last segment but
when i say that i specifically mean like
you know mahomes watkins tyree kill
those three guys they're being paid a
lot of money and the throw those three
guys came through and i should put
kelsey in there as well because some of
his catches were big as well but you
know just watkins being right around 100
yards tyree kill getting over 100 and
then mahomes delivering that way this
team was built around their offense and
their ability to strike with big plays
in the pass game and when they needed it
the most
the star power came through the people
that brett veach and andy reid put a lot
of time and money into they came through
in the biggest moment and that's why
they went and got these guys and that's
why they're the super bowl champs
yeah and you know damien williams uh
actually made a late run at becoming the
mvp with a couple of touchdowns in the
fourth quarter over a hundred yards
rushing thanks to the one that was
popped that that iced the game back when
you know oh it's 24 20 and the chiefs
have the ball but there's still a chance
here and if they if they do oh there
goes damian williams the game's over
right right but you know
mahomes did not play like the mvp
but
mahomes earned it in that fourth quarter
and yeah and
he he gets the amnesia award we we talk
all the time about defensive backs
having a short memory and forgetting the
bad play and moving on and we don't have
to see patrick mahomes do that very
often last night was the first time he
had multiple interceptions since the
54-51
track meet against the rams in november
of 2018. he did not have more than one
interception in any game since then to
have those two plays
the one where he got frustrated and
threw the ball right to fred warner and
then when he threw the ball behind
tyreek hill
that's one of those moments where
and and i i perceive this look sometimes
we talked about it with a player last
week that from afar when we see a guy's
demeanor that's when a guy's demeanor
can morph into i just want to go home
right right right it's not my night
get me the hell out of here that that is
something that we've seen lesser players
do but you know all night long patrick
mahomes never looked phased by any of it
he looked calm he looked relaxed and he
forgot about those interceptions right
he's the guy who went to the sideline
when they were down 24 nothing to the
texans and said we have the opportunity
to do something great he never gives up
and when you have those supreme
god-given abilities i think it's easier
to think you're still in it right yeah
and and and because they they know they
know right that they can find the gas
pedal and mash it at any time and he
forgot about
all the you know fender benders that he
had through the first three and a half
quarters and he found that gas pedal and
off they went and and and that is
for as rare as the talent
is chris the mindset
three years into his nfl career is even
more rare no that that's what it is i
mean you're right i mean just he's he's
never gets you know what i want to say
flabbergasted he's never like deer in
the headlights never
like last night was the most you've ever
seen him be that way
and you still felt like hey he's not
calm he's not i mean he's still calm
he's rattled you weren't like oh my gosh
now he didn't play great and he i do
think he was tentative and a little
scared to just let the ball go a number
of times you know because i think he was
worried about making the big mistake he
was trying to be a little too perfect
but him not playing great is still
everybody else is great and that's when
you know you're great is because when
you can just play hey i've had better
and we are still sitting here on a
monday after the super bowl going damn
if it weren't for him they couldn't win
the football game uh that's that's when
you know you've gone into another
stratosphere and that's what he has a
chance to do here
and and you know the thing is
that just that that uh that mindset that
idea that and and
it really is uncanny when you've
struggled the way you've struggled and i
think once he finally decided to just
let it go
there's a hell of a lesson that's going
to carry over to next year and is going
to make him even better chris because
he's going to have that memory of what
happens when he tries to be careful sure
and when you finally say screw it i'm
not going to be careful you know what
that means next year he's never going to
be careful he's going to say i'm always
going to trust my abilities when i start
not trusting my abilities and start
restraining my skill set is when things
don't go the way they should i'm gonna
go out there and play the way i know i'm
capable of all the time and take chances
all the time and be that guy all the
time no matter how big the stage is yeah
no you're right i mean he just he's uh
never shied away from it
loves the big stage loves the big moment
thrives with the ball in his hands in
those moments i mean he's he's
officially reached that status where i
mean we know yeah he gets the ball last
he's gonna come through it's almost like
a it's a it's a it's inevitable just
doesn't matter and that's where he's
amazing and my next superlative is gonna
be like a little bit of like get off my
lawn all right get off my lawn with like
oh shanahan and his play calling and all
this crap like that lost him the
football game you know listen i
understand that we can't all sit here
and be monday morning quarterbacks you
know again okay he threw the ball on
second and five after they ran the ball
for five million yards up the middle i'm
not gonna sit here and just sit back and
let like the critics just go oh you know
to everybody's point oh well well he he
had to be aggressive i mean it's patrick
mahomes we've seen this story before
they get on fire and you gotta go oh we
need to put them away we can't just
think we're gonna run the ball and play
that way and conservative you know he
threw a high high completion percentage
type pass over the middle a really
awesome player and chris jones did a
great job of getting his hands up to
knock the ball down i understand the
optics of the situation aren't gonna
look good on shanahan i get that but i
you know again i i you know me mike i've
never been one to to be shy from
criticizing anybody friend or not friend
and i don't look at it and going oh
that's an egregious mistake i don't look
at it and go oh that was so stupid the
49ers weren't just dominating the line
of scrimmage in the run game like this
was like you know
uh you know the greatest
like they weren't just bludging them
that's all i want to say a lot of their
success on the run came through shanahan
trick runs with debo samuel on the edge
and
the the drive before he got stuck in a
second and nine situation because he was
running on first and ten and they got
nowhere so i just don't want to hear
this i understand it wasn't perfect
i get it but it wasn't like egregious to
where like i'm not gonna stand for
people sitting here just going oh
shanahan blew it he doesn't know how to
manage the game i don't think that at
all i just don't look at it that way
you know
let me ask you this question yes go
ahead
who's there to tell him or to nudge him
or to maybe challenge him in real time
if maybe he's not calling his best
possible game or maybe he's not doing
what he needs to do does he have anyone
who can be that voice that conscience
that that angel on his shoulder that
tries to steer him the right way
probably not i don't know if he does you
know those are things he has not told me
so i have no inside info there
you know i do know that this is an
extremely intelligent human being who's
really well thought out and doesn't just
throw darts at a dartboard and go well i
think i'll do that
he has rhyme and reason behind
everything
and i think that's you know yeah i don't
know if there's a guy in his headset
telling hey don't do that you know but i
don't know at this point i think he's
earned the right to be able to make that
decision on himself he's kind of
successful he's kind of good at what he
does
so i don't know if anybody's going to
sit there and challenge him in that way
and again if we can pull that play up at
some point i would love to watch it
let's watch it you know to me it looks
like the guy's wide open over the middle
it's not like it's not like he called
some daring crazy play
you know really they blocked chris jones
really well to where he gave up
on the play itself so here's first and
ten now look there he is kittle's open
he's wide open
but chris jones made a great play and
got his hands up and they blocked him so
good he gave up on the pass rush so he
put his hands up i'm not going to sit
here and go oh shanahan you're such an
idiot you're so you're what are you
doing
i don't it's 20 to 17 and my homes
looked like he was getting on fire and i
think he felt like we got to get
momentum and start moving the ball too
i've got one more very quick one before
we go and this was this is the only bet
your gambling money
kids award and it goes to
the patrick mahomes over under for
rushing yards he was well over the range
of 29 and a half to 33 and a half with
44 yards and with the kneel down's
usually two or three yards he lost 15
rushing yards wow on kneel downs late in
the game to put him under
the over under
whether it was 29 and a half up to 33
and a half whatever it was it was the
under the over blew it by any measure
all because of those kneel downs so do
not bet anything that you need if you're
gonna bet be responsible
budget it do not risk money that you
need to pay your bills uh because
inevitably you will lose at some point
and it will hurt as badly as it had to
hurt last night
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports